the US president issuing a stern warning
to Iran if in any way US naval ships are
harassed in the Persian Gulf by Iranian
fast boats in the words of the US
president he will make sure they are
shot out of the water if they get close
to our boats the US president saying
that the US Navy is 100% prepared for
any sort of engagement I also had the
opportunity in the White House briefing
to ask the US president for his reaction
to the launch of that military satellite
by the IRGC mr. president I want to ask
you about lunch if the military
satellite fire bomb wanted to get
responsive do you see this an
advancement of the missile program well
they say no okay they say also it was
for television does anybody really
believe that they would have better
television in Iran so they say no we're
watching Iran very closely very closely
we know more about Iran than they do
right now we know more than they do so
we know all about it we watched it we
knew it was going up we followed it very
closely
they say it was for television now the
president would not answer the question
about whether he was concerned the
United States had projected any
vulnerability in terms of military
readiness the fact that there's been an
outbreak of coronavirus on the aircraft
carrier the USS Roosevelt or even that
the commander in chief Donald Trump has
been consumed with dealing with
coronavirus inside the United States
again no answer from the US president on
that question however it is important to
know that on Wednesday the US President
did contact the Emir of Qatar the
readout from both sides says that well
they did not mention Iran specifically
they do say that they discussed issues
important to the region